- I hate the taste of fish.
- I love this.
- It's all over my mouth.
(hip hop music)
- A bag inside a bag.
- Oh, double bagging it.
- Oh, no, it smells like
a cat that's in the bath.
- I know exactly what that is.
- Ow!
- We haven't even had it
and it's already terrible.
- Much better than I
thought it was gonna taste.
- You don't like it?
- No.
- It's sweet, oh no, now it starts bad.
- It was good and then it was bad.
- It's so fishy, though.
- It's like I'm eating an aquarium!
- I love it.
- [Voiceover] Taro crispy
fish snack, spicy flavored.
- Another fish.
- Ah, more fish.
- Who puts you up to this, my girlfriend?
- They look like dried skin.
- This chip needs some lotion.
- They sort of carved a
triangle off of a mummy.
- What's it smell like?
- These are like fishy Doritos!
Oh, God!
- Ah!
- They taste like dried skin.
I think it's gross that they're
making fish meat into chips.
- I'm not gonna try a second one.
- This is so disgusting!
- I love it, this is great.
- These always take you on a journey
and I never like where we go.
- Yep!
- Damn it.
- Go for it.
- Alright.
- Tastes like corn pops!
- Yeah.
- These taste like corn pops.
- These are really good.
- Okay, well I see an
octopus, he looks really cute.
- That's just the guy that
makes-- he's the chef.
- He's like, "I'm the only smart one."
- Corn, sugar, cuddle fish.
- I like cuddle fish I'm down.
- Are corn pops just cuddle fish flavored?
Is that what I'm learning here?
- [Voiceover] These are
scallop flavored Lays.
- This looks familiar.
I have the fish sweats.
- This one's a little too much.
- Scallops whole thing
is, like, it's texture.
It's buttery texture, you
put it into a chip form,
you just got that taste
that's like, "Hmm, whatever."
- I don't mind these.
- All my senses are
rebelling against me, now.
- Like a sea shell.
- Like somebody's bad breath.
- It's not bad, it starts
off in a really good place.
- Okay, here's what it does have;
it has this, like, Hot Cheeto appeal.
- So, like, what you have to
do is just keep eating them
so you never get to that end
moment where you're like,
"What was that?"
- We got Mee Krob.
- Yeah it's like
if you made a rice crispy treat
out of a block of instant Ramen.
- We'll see what happens in the mouth.
- Whoa.
- What is this?
- It's got a good texture.
- For sure.
- I think it can't decide what it is.
- Old soy sauce!
- It taste like we're
eating, like, a loofah.
- It's a great garnish.
- Yeah, it tastes like
the memory of a Chinese fish.
- I don't know if I like this memory.
- Yeah this is really good.
- I like that!
- But I just want to keep eating more.
Great with dinner, too!
- Great with dinner, too.
Also works as an adhesive.
- I don't know what these flavors are.
- I like it.
- These are great.
(upbeat music)
- Thai food.